la mia vita oggi ha bisogno di questo vi
racconterò tra poco di come ho capito
innanzitutto una cosa quando feci la mia
scelta
forse è racchiusa in una frase non amo
meno gli uomini ma più la natura magari
non erano queste le parole esatte che
avevo in mente il giorno in cui feci che
la scelta ma certo ne rimasi incantata
quando levi di scritte nere su bianco da
una penna che non era la mia sono
infatti versi del poeta al byron
da allora sono la mia guida ero poco più
che una bambina ma legittimano nel modo
più tecnico della parola la mia
esistenza in questo mondo e ciò che ho
deciso di fare inclusa la mia scelta
recente più drastica da quattro anni
passano la maggior parte della mia vita
a bordo di una nave di sea shepard è
un'organizzazione internazionale che si
occupa di oceani la bob barker è stata
la mia casa per molti mesi
io sono profondamente convinta che sia
fondamentale assumersi la responsabilità
di operare una scelta per salvare il
futuro
certo è più facile non sapere cambiare
canale e voltare pagina perché sapere
implica scegliere ea volte le scelte si
scontrano con i piaceri personali le
abitudini richiedono rinunce sacrifici
io ho fatto la mia scelta e l'incontro
con sea shepherd peraltro del tutto
casuale
fu amore a prima vista per quell'azione
diretta in difesa dell'ambiente degli
animali che fa la differenza e di cui
avevo bisogno
quindi mi lasciai tutto alle spalle casa
lavoro famiglia vita privata
se faccio un passo indietro nel tempo
quando conduceva una vita
chiamiamo la normale non posso
dimenticare la depressione incalzante
per vivere una vita che non era mai
stata la mia e quando mi resi conto che
non stavo più vivendo la paura
attanagliava la gola in una morsa che
non mi faceva respirare per giorni prima
che fosse troppo tardi decisi di mollare
tutto e onorare le parole di byron
perché se non ho paura di morire ho
molta paura di non vivere a bordo delle
navi io faccio la fotografa devo
documentare ciò che accade in mare
aperto spesso a migliaia di chilometri
dalla costa della civiltà dove la legge
esiste ma non ci sono i controlli quindi
è come se non ci fosse ecco sea shepard
sia sicura che la legge sia rispettata
vi parlavo prima di etica morale ideali
ma la legge qualcosa di diverso
è qualcosa di concreto tangibile regola
le nostre vite per ragioni più che ovvia
ed io in quella che è la mia scelta di
oggi ho deciso anche in nome della legge
di salvare ed aiutare gli abitanti del
mio adorato grande blu vi racconto una
cosa ogni anno nelle acque dell'oceano
antartico si radunano migliaia di balene
immigrazione da nord vanno a nutrirsi di
krill è un ciclo che si ripete da
millenni non delicato meraviglioso
equilibrio sino a quando l'essere umano
non decise che le balene
avrebbero rappresentato una forma di
sostentamento prima ma di mero
arricchimento economico poi tanto da
cacciarli in massa portandole quasi
all'estinzione così che nel 1986 la
commissione internazionale sulla
baleneria decretò che uccidere balene un
reato ma ci mise la deroga della ricerca
scientifica
il giappone pone allora sulle fiancate
delle navi l'enorme scritta researc
presenta la commissione presunti
progetti di ricerca del tutto insensate
e continua a dc ad uccidere indisturbato
migliaia di balene lo va a fare la dove
è più facile cacciarle è più difficile
che qualcuno vada a disturbarli il
santuario dei ceci dei cetacei
nell'oceano meridionale da quel 1986 al
2002 uccide illegalmente più di 25.000
cetacei sea shepard non resta a guardare
la carta mondiale della natura parla
chiaro ciascun cittadino del mondo ha il
diritto e il dovere di agire per la
salvaguardia della vita selvatica e
degli ecosistemi naturali si preparano
allora le navi e gli equipaggi per
fermare quella che è una mattanza
illegale irresponsabile e cruenta
uccidere una balena non è mica una cosa
facile
un arpione esplosivo viene conficcato
nel corpo dell'animale che lottando
disperatamente per la vita
muore dopo una lunghissima agonia per
diventare carne in scatola che ormai
quasi nessuno mangia né in giappone né
altrove o per diventare cosmetici con
sea shepherd si mettono in campo tutte
le forze inclusa la nave stessa ma
l'arma più potente a disposizione dei
pastori del mare la passione dei singoli
volontari che non si fermano di fronte
ad alcun pericolo pur di fermare
l'ingiustizia
racconto uno dei tanti episodi che ho
vissuto
mi trovavo sul ponte più alto della
bomba harker doveva appunto documentare
gli avvenimenti ricordo quei momenti
ancora con fortissima emozione mi
sembrava ad essere stata catapultata
all'interno di un film d'azione perché
davvero non riuscivo a credere a cio a
cui stavo assistendo essendo che la
stagione di caccia è lunga quanto
l'estate antartica almeno tre mesi
la nave fabbrica giapponese doveva
accostarsi alla nave cisterna per fare
rifornimento di gasolio che è un altra
attività illecita in quelle acque e si
ritorna a parlare di leggere
ebbene disperato il comandante della
nave giapponese spinge con forza le sue
8 mila tonnellate di nave contro la
nostra piccola bob in onda con gli
idranti di acqua gelida salata per
impedirci di governare la nave per me
nonostante il grandangolo della macchina
fotografica un enorme gigante che avanza
senza remore contro di noi
la bob sinclair ha pericolosamente su un
fianco
il cuore batte forte ma stranamente non
per una sensazione di pericolo quanto
per il timore che riescano davvero a
spostarci che ci possono demolire far
fallire il nostro intento
mi sento ripetere non mollare peter non
mollare
scoprirò soltanto nei giorni successivi
cosa stava accadendo proprio sotto di me
nel ponte di comando la fermezza di
peter e nel nostro giovanissimo capitano
io non mi muoverò se vuoi prendere il
mio posto mi devi affondare
win it
parlando invece morto
nato
grazie
com'è andata a finire che la volta beh
che da lassù tra le ami lamiere spezzate
della bob vedo quella gigante sagoma
nera arretrare sconfitta li stavano
mandando a casa senza gasolio di fatto
avevamo vinto la battaglia quel giorno
avevamo veramente salvato le barene
anche quel giorno vi parlavo prima di
legge
ebbene dopo quattro anni di processo
alla corte internazionale di giustizia
dell'aia
finalmente arriva la sentenza 31 marzo
la baleneria giapponese è una caccia è
esclusivamente commerciale con la
scritta researche sulle fiancate e
riconosciuta come una bugia uno
stratagemma
da quel giorno veto immediato al governo
di un tonico di rilasciare le quote di
caccia ha prevalso la legge per fortuna
ma ora vi porto da un'altra parte del
mondo
siccome ho scelto di difendere gli
oceani
dopo la stagione antartica mi sposto il
nord atlantico
decido di navigare attorno a questo
piccolo arcipelago di isole di isole fær
øer che sono una zona di passaggio
migratorio di gruppi di grandi delfini
questi splendidi animali di una
riconosciuta intelligenza e sensibilità
e con un senso di famiglia davvero pari
al nostro si avventurano nei pressi
delle isole e fiduciosi e stanchi in
cerca di riposo e di cibo ma ahimè
trovano invece la morte gli isolani li
uccidono in massa senza risparmiare
nessuno
e ciò che un tempo era una caccia
sicuramente di sussistenza
da decenni ormai è soltanto una festa la
festa una cruenta terribile mattanza
davvero sanguinaria famiglie intere che
vengono sterminate un patrimonio
genetico
che sparisce nel nulla per sempre come
lo è ogni estinzione per poi scoprire
che la maggior parte delle loro carni
macellate torna ad accumularsi sul fondo
del mare in veri e propri cimiteri
ho visto uomini di ogni età inclusi i
ragazzini entrare nell'acqua sino alla
cinta con il desiderio di uccidere con
grandissima soddisfazione quegli animali
innocenti e indifesi
nel mentre le loro donne si godono lo
spettacolo dalla costa addirittura
spingono i bimbi sulla spiaggia affinché
assistano al massacro io non potrei mai
immaginare di avere un figlio che con un
coltellaccio in mano si avventura ad
uccidere terribilmente un animale
indifeso non per fame ma per il solo
gusto di uccidere con quali valori
potrebbe crescere quelle barbariche
tradizioni trovano l'appoggio anche del
governo danese che per contrastare noi e
chi come noi si oppone a tutto ciò mette
in campo addirittura le navi da guerra
la polizia la scorsa estate mi trovavo
appunto alle isole far oer e stavo
cercando di andare a fotografare lo
sterminio di un centinaio di globicefali
che purtroppo non avrei più potuto
aiutare sono stata arrestata ancora
prima di arrivare sul posto
pensate mi trovavo a bordo di un
piccolissimo gommoncino avevo commesso
la macchina fotografica
nei giorni successivi l'accusa il
processo la condanna al carcere per aver
avuto l'intenzione di fermare la
carneficina con una macchina fotografica
che naturalmente mi venne sequestrata
non si possono
credetemi non si possono scordare le
urla di paura e di dolore di quegli
animali
il terrore che vivono negli ultimi
lunghi momenti della loro vita nel
tentativo di sopravvivere con gli adulti
che cercano di proteggere i piccoli e
intanto il mare si colora del rosso
intenso del loro sangue non si dimentica
più
vedete balene e delfini contribuiscono
con il rimescolamento delle acque con il
nutrimento del fitoplancton
all'ossigenazione dell'area del nostro
pianeta proteggere quegli animali è
anche un modo per tutelare gli oceani e
tutelare gli oceani è un modo per
garantirci la possibilità di vivere
perché se c'è qualcosa che accomuna
tutti noi esseri viventi indistintamente
indipendentemente dalla specie è che per
vivere respiriamo
ed allora io penso sono fermamente
convinta che non possiamo sempre
aspettarci che sia qualcun altro ad
intervenire nel sistemare le cose ancor
più quelle che ci riguardano tutti
indistintamente in tutto il mondo perché
noi siamo gli altri e il pianeta che
viviamo è la nostra casa tutti in cuor
nostro desideriamo che le cose cambino
per un futuro migliore
scommetto anche tutti voi ma quanti sono
davvero disposti a cambiare un po di se
stessi io ci sto provando
e il primo passo del mio cambiamento è
stato quello di passare da un egoistico
pensiero io qui adesso al tutti ovunque
sempre grazie
poi scusatemi